yes
on the fair dealing defense
is the proceeding case and uh the error
that we say the judge fellaini has been
failing to follow its guidance
as to identifying what are or may
arguably be the current events and what
activities are quotes for the purpose of
reporting such things
can i ask you to take out proceeding
it's in tab 12 of the authorities bundle
and just to give you a bit of context
about the case it's an appeal against
the finding of copyright infringement
made
at a trial
it's the case about you've just lost me
for a second um i'm sorry mr spent where
have you gone i'm i'm taking you to
authorities bundled tab 12 so
first bundle tab 12. it's a case called
procebun it's a decision of this court
it's an appeal i'm just going to tell my
lord to my lady a little bit about the
facts so you understand what was being
debated it's an appeal against finding a
copyright infringement
made at trial
and the case was about a tv programme
made by carlton
which was criticizing the culture of
checkbook journalism
back in the days of people finding
themselves in unusual circumstances and
finding their way to people like max
clifford and then into the papers or in
this case a tv program
being paid for their story
and the carlton program
included material taken from a german
proseben tv program
that had featured a person who'd become
very well known at the time for
a pregnancy with eight babies i think
her name was
forward and so the program was an
instance of checkbook journalism but
apart from that not specifically
relevant to carlton's objective
but it used extracts from the proceeding
program for its program
those were the facts
can we pick it up at page 244 of the
bundle
so that's
613 of the report just around letter c
you see there that the degree to which
the challenged use competes with
exploitation of copyright by the user is
very important
that reflects the fact that most cases
actually concern a work that is being or
will be commercially exploited
and commercial competition is a
well-known factor
then the passage goes on
the extent of the use is also relevant
but its relevance
depends very much on the circumstances
that's just below letter c
because then the mention of hubbard and
vosper
where it was contemplated that the
quotation of an entire short work may be
fair dealing
and that's echoing a point that i've
been making earlier
it isn't just a question of how much in
the sense of the proportion of the work
because taking all of it even could be
fair dealing
now the judgment then turns to questions
of what the requirement of
the fair dealing sections in the act
were referring to where they talk about
for the purpose of
it's obviously either reporting current
events or criticism or review because
they're the two particular
provisions
can i show you a couple of important
passages on page 245
if i can
the first is between b and c
we see for the purpose of
should be approached in the sense of
in the context of
or as part of an exercise in
and i
invite my lords and my lady to note that
and the second important passage is down
at letter g
both the phrases criticism or review
and reporting current events
are expressions of wide and indefinite
scope
and they should be interpreted liberally
please also know there was little
assistance from comparisons with other
expressions such as current affairs or
news
so we say
current events is
broad to be interpreted liberally and
not to be equated with
or substituted with the words news or
current affairs
and so putting these passages together
what we're talking about
when looking about looking to see
whether use that is complained of
is within this defense
not necessarily that the defense will
succeed because fairness is obviously
the further
requirement but in terms of whether it
falls within for the purpose of
use but for the purpose of reporting
current events
it simply has to be in the context of or
as part of an exercise
in reporting current events as
interpreted liberally
as i've said of course it still has to
be fair
and that's where requirements as to
the amount taken and so on would come in
now just finishing the case the
conclusion was that the carlton program
was made for the chris for the purposes
of criticism or review of works of
checkbook journalism generally you see
that at letter d on page 248.
and the appeal was allowed
and
that
i.e
the the defense was made good in that
case
and it's important this case in my
submission and perhaps unfortunate that
the judge
didn't refer to it at all because it
shows the correct approach
for current events and what is for the
purpose of it is wide
now the judge
what the judge did do in paragraph 153
of the judgment was to distill from our
paragraph 37
of the defense five topics as putative
current events
and can i actually take you to the
pleading
to show you
what we pleaded
and that's so that's
tab 21 of
cb2
towards the front of that volume and
it's page
368. you've
had it out a little bit earlier in my
submissions where i was contrasting
the grounds
where i was contrasting that paragraph
with the one for free speech sorry it's
363 the page not 368.
and can you see just below the top hole
one of the things we identify is this
by mid february
2019
the existence of the letter and a
description of the contents of the
letter
and the claimant's version of her
conduct towards her father had very
recently entered the public domain and
was being reported widely
now that
doesn't make its way into the judges
list at least as not so framed
what we do have
in his paragraph
is his subparagraph b in 153
which is
the people article disclosing the
existence of the letter and giving a
description but the broader description
as being
the contents of the letter and the
claimant's version of her conduct
towards her father is not there
we say
it was plainly raised in the pleading
and can probably be considered well
arguable as a current event as the
pleading alleges those things were being
widely reported
we also say the judge didn't follow the
approach in pro stephen when he took too
narrow review the more general item
identified in the judge's paragraph a
and that's the claimant's conduct awards
and estrangement with her father and
that was also being widely reported
as we've seen current events doesn't
mean it has to be current affairs it's
to be understood liberally
and the point i'd make to my lords and
my lady is if it be shown at trial that
a wide variety of media outlets are
reporting something
it's obviously well arguable that it may
be properly understood as a current
event
in the sense used in this fair dealing
provision
moreover whether or not i'm correct
about those two criticisms that i make
as to the judge's view as to what
qualifies
the articles do report the items that
the judge accepted are arguably current
events
for instance mr michael's reaction to
and view of the people article
his dispute with the version of the
claimant's conduct towards him and his
contradiction of and dispute with the
version of her conduct towards him that
includes
if i may say so also the handwriting
article
which follows the modern approach of
online reporting where the same basic
story
is put online more than once in multiple
online versions with additional angles
or focus added
that article still does those things
the use
in all of the articles is in the context
of reporting those matters
and what the judge is really doing by
saying it's not for those purposes this
is his paragraph 155 and 156 of his
judgment
is alighting the question of fairness
and what is with the question of what is
in the context of reporting current
events
one sees quite clearly he thinks too
much was taken to be legitimately for
that purpose and so we see at the end of
para 155 to the judgment where the
sentiment
is that what it was reproduced wasn't
legitimate reporting
basically his analysis was too much
was taken it's the same analysis as the
privacy free speech balance
and so he says in paragraph 156 the use
was for the purpose of reporting the
contents of the letter which according
to him is not the current event
as i've already already explained we
disagree and i've submitted that its
existence and description had recently
entered the public domain and was the
current event being reported on but
either way that's not an answer to the
submission that it was in the context of
or part of an exercise in reporting the
things the judge accepted were common at
current events
whether it went too far in the sense it
took too much is a question for fairness
and he's allied
those two together so
that's our final point on fair dealing
the judge
wrongly failed to follow the pro seven
approach and correctly assess
whether the use was in accordance with
its guidance
and for the purpose of reporting current
events should be approached liberally in
the way that i've explained
now that is the end of my note sorry can
you just explain
how that fits in with what the judge
says at 156.
he seems to be saying that
only part of
there is part of the reproduction
that links in with the um
current events
issue but only part of it yeah and the
rest doesn't
exactly
but what's wrong with that well my point
is that's a question of fairness what
his view really is is you've taken too
much
um
to be fairly doing it for that
and
what what's undoubtedly right a bit
someone isn't he's saying also the bits
that you've taken don't relate to that
topic as it were
looking crudely well he's saying he's
basically saying you've gone too far to
be doing uh for legitimate reporting
and what we say is that the correct
approach to section 30 is that
are you doing in the context of an
exercise in
reporting current events as
through liberty
that article is doing that we are doing
it in the context of that
i totally accept that there may be a
further question that have you taken too
much gone too far
than is
appropriate but that in my submission is
a question of fairness doesn't mean
you're not doing it in the context of
reporting
the current events that he identified
so i just say that the judges are
lighting those two
concepts
incorrectly in my submission
the article do
report the matters that he's identified
so it is in the context of that
he should have been addressing quantity
under the heavy fairness
yeah
i think unless anybody around this
those are my submissions unless my lord
or my lady has any further
lady
maloney friend uh mr caldecott
um
devoted a considerable amount of his
submissions to
uh
the proposition that this is a case that
proliferates with tribal issues
um
i don't think the court would be
surprised to hear me say that um
from our point of view this is actually
a very straightforward case which the
defendant has made inordinately
complicated
not quite as contentious evidently i
suspect as the prince of wales case
but certainly judging by the um
amount of the core bundle that is
devoted to the pleadings
it has it does bristle on its face
with um issues
the case does raise an important
question about the right to control
personal and private information in the
form of a letter
various
facets of that are
notable one
that this is
a letter it's correspondence
and correspondence is um
separately mentioned as deserving of
protection under article 8
but its correspondence
within a family
that relates to
the
personal life
of the claimant and the feelings of the
claimant
and the fact that she
describes
the letter in the terms that she does
um
namely an account of what transpired
which is uh perhaps not doing it justice
uh makes it nonetheless personal
and private for that
so the starting point in all cases have
to have a starting point
is
that the claimant's
article eight rights are on the face of
it
tripoli engaged
it's her right to private life
to family life
and correspondence
and for what it's worth the european
court of human rights has endorsed the
proposition that
there is
something
significant in the fact that
correspondence is not qualified by
private in other words
any correspondence in principle
it's capable of engaging the article 8
right that probably doesn't matter here
because there can be no doubt
that the subject of this
letter made it highly personal
so we adhere to the way it was put in
front of
the learning judge below
which is that
the case does raise a question which
doesn't appear to have been
addressed before certainly in the modern
law of privacy
about who has the right for first
publication
of a private letter
bearing in mind this was a letter
of which extensive contents
around about half of it it's a long
letter
were first published by the defendant
without the consent of the claimant
that's obviously an important murray
factor
or even notification
it was the defendant who first brought
the contents of the letter
into the public domain
and
picking up on something my lord the
master of the roles is that right
yes defendant first brought the contents
you mean the actual words indeed and
will not be not the fact
quite so and there is
a very material
distinction
for the reasons that melania friend
quoted from our skeleton argument
the letter is in some ways analogous to
a photograph in fact in some ways it's
more potentially
revealing or intrusive than a photograph
because of what it says
about so to speak the the inner life
of the writer of the letter
and so we don't uh shrink from the
proposition
that
if
domestic law is to do its job properly
and to be convention compliant
a newspaper that
brings into the public to make
extensively the contents of a private
letter
uh needs
particularly good reasons
to justify that
now lord malay i will come back to the
um the stage one
point
uh but for the for present purposes if
uh um
you will
kindly assume that that
stage has been
passed in this case
we say it plainly has
um the key issue which
the judge had to address and i hope this
is a
helpful way of putting it
was given
the claimant's reasonable expectation of
privacy
in relation to the contents of the
letter
note contents not the fact of it nor
even a description of its contents which
is the way it is pleaded by the defense
a description of its contents
um did the claimant
directly or indirectly put
anything
into the public domain
this through people magazine
which
arguably waived
or compromised
those privacy rights
such as to justify the defendant in
publishing
those extensive
extracts of the letter is that really
the question
that was the question where does the
waiver question come from
it's a matter of law well it's it
perhaps it's not helpful as a shorthand
for were her rights extinguished
or
outweighed
well i mean it's it's all about
outweighed yes
i mean it's all about the balancing
exercise between the articulate and out
of the ten rights
and the the two
um free speech rights on the other side
there's
of thomas markle to reply
to what had been put in the people
article
and the question of what was put into
the public domain which is inherent in
your
formulation as well
yes but
it's not that difficult as you rightly
said it's a balancing exercise and the
question is did the judge do it
effectively or was he able to do it
bearing in mind the evidential situation
on the summary judgment just the case
that um this again this is by way of
headline because i'll come back to it
that does
raise the question
of what it is for a defendant to show as
it were on the pleadings
or at a summary judgment application
well does it i mean i thought we'd had
legions of cases which told us what had
to be established in order to refuse
some of the judgment yes
the question which which has
some novelty here is in the context of a
private letter
given the strong starting point
what
arguably
constitutes a viable justification for
the extensive publication of the
extracts from the letter
and
where i do
strongly differ from a learned friend
is on the
um
question
of the subjective belief
of mr martin
what do you say about the subjective
belief
it's
irrelevant at stage one or stage
it's
two
that he believes he's being introduced
yes it's for the court to decide
objectively at both stages
uh what is proportionate
and also
in accordance with the ethics of
journalism
which is a european court phrase but it
has its
perhaps the
most obvious answer to the
contention that mr markle's
belief is something that needs to be
tried out
in a in this privacy claim
is it a belief that i i didn't hear mr
caldecott say that his belief
needed to be tried out
the honesty of his belief and i didn't
hear that either
it's not a question of mr markle's
honesty
it's a question of where the balance of
freedom of speech
lies and whether he has a right to reply
to the newspaper
to the allegations in the people
and the mr caldecott says the
allegations in the people were far more
extensive than the judge understood them
and he didn't record them accurately
and that uh when taken
for what they were mr markle because
he was saying he was about i mean to put
it loosely
they were saying he was a bad person
and he had a right to some kind of right
which had to be balanced to say he
wasn't
and
where the truth lies
perhaps only can be ascertained at trial
lord i i respectfully agree with the
first part but not the second yeah well
i know you don't agree with the second i
mean that's what mr caldecott says yes
that's what he says and and he relies
for that purpose on an alien
concept which is the um concept of
a species of qualified privilege in
libel
namely
reply to attack well that's that's a
terribly
interesting question
as to whether we lift those authorities
into the law of privacy
but i i wonder whether it really matters
because plainly one factor
in the balancing exercise concerning
freedom of speech in a privacy case
is the
response that a person produced in
public may wish
to make
and whether you apply exactly the same
rules as one might have applied in a
long time ago in defamation
feels to me like a similar question to
how many angels can stand on the point
of an eagle we are only concerned in
this case
whether with whether or not there were
facts which ought to have been tried out
before the judge took a final view i
mean
you push at an open door um mr rushbook
if you want to tell me that the judge
may well have been right
of course
he may well
and the question only is whether he was
right to decide those questions without
a full trial yes
and relevant to that question is is what
is it that he should have been trying
and i i think in in
fairness
um to our argument the
the proposition was urged on you by mr
cornickers
that mr markle honestly believed both
that he had a right to reply in those
terms well of course he would say that
yes and and and moreover that evidence
as to the impact on his reputation would
be relevant at trial that's completely
irrelevant indeed in libel cases it's
for the judge to decide the impact
certainly is a threshold
question well i mean when you when you
cross-examine witnesses you
probably do focus on whether they
honestly think things
but ultimately what one has to decide is
the rather difficult balancing exercise
between
the article 8 bytes to which you've
eluded and the article 10 rights to
which mr caldecott is yes
that depends on the facts
up to a point because as we as we say
the um
[Music]
the question of what objectively
uh
could amount
to a justification if i can use that
word
uh in the sort of candle sense
he's one for the judge to assess
and in an appropriate case
if he is in as good a position as we say
he was because it's an objective test
at the summary judgment stage
to form the view that there is no real
prospect of the balance coming down in
favor of the defense of the defendant
weighing in those rights
then he is entitled and in our
submission he's bound
to give judgment for the claimant
um partly because that is the
appropriate way of giving effect to her
article eight rights
a trial in a case like this would um
certainly if conducted the way the
defendant wanted to be
a further intrusive process of course
if claimed the defendant is right and it
gets its trial then too bad
but if we're right that there is no need
for a trial it is an extra reason it's a
good reason
as a matter of
the practice of privacy law
nothing else
that
the court in an appropriate case will
say no it doesn't need to go to trial
and it shouldn't go to trump
and um
my lord is right there are relatively
few summary judgment applications
in privacy cases but as mr white said i
think in the court below everything was
new once
uh and um
we are still to an extent
uh in relatively new territory
but then that's the
because there will be clear cases and
that's absolutely fine and um we should
we don't close our minds to anything in
these courts or at least try not to
um
the question is where you have a
balancing exercise which has to be
undertaken on the basis of hotly
contested
facts and i'm not talking about
um
motivations and talking about real facts
what did x say to y in a text message or
a series of text messages
was that true
if it was not true does it entitle x to
say
in answer to why something that was true
or not now all that
does have to be balanced on the basis of
facts and
it appears
that there were a number of facts
which the judge was not able to take
into account because he didn't know them
at least
and and um
that
sort of brings a little bit of alarm
bells with me because i say well
is this a
can it be a proper balancing exercise if
the facts
are coming out as rapidly as they seem
to be in this case well i i'm going to
try to assuage those concerns because
where we
uh say that the judge in this case
correctly drew the line is between facts
which did need to be tried
and those which didn't
i say need to be tried i mean could be
relevant to the outcome
and what he did for the purpose of this
exercise
is he assumed
what we said
were all relevant facts in favor of the
defendant
and and the uh judgment is um replete
with um examples of that which i will
take you to
what he doesn't or didn't need to try
was the he said she said dispute about
the text messages
for example
because they
are not as we submit
logically capable of affecting
the outcome of the balance can i ask you
this because this concerns me
if it is true
that
um
the
one step one
of the claimant or mr markle had ignored
the other
right
at a particular period an important
period in their lives
and a newspaper article says
one side
and the other person wishes to produce
evidence publicly to say that's not true
it's the other
surely that is relevant
no with respect
no because even if even if it's
perfectly clear that the newspaper
article
is wrong
on the text messages and the
circumstances recorded in a letter
not relevant to the question of whether
the letter
is a freedom of speech in the letter is
that way no because what one has to look
at is
what the article
published from the letter
and then
against that background
assess
the extent to which arguably
the
people are supreme
upon which the defendant hangs its case
nearly all of its case
to what extent could
the defendant's deployment of the text
of the
contents of the letter
be a justifiable
correction of the record is the phrase
i'll use because that's more
i think less it's more orthodox because
it's the strand of privacy that all the
people tend to talk on correcting the
record
uh that is a an aspect to public
interest and it's the um aspect of that
can you make that submission again so i
can write it down about when it is that
one may take into account it's only a
question of taking into account
the correction of the record
the defendant
as we say it's required to seeks to
justify its publication
by reference to people
people is the
pretext i don't mean that majority
on the face of the articles it's the
pretext for publishing the letter
what the judge had to do
was to look at the people article what
it said
that
both with the text of the letter
what the defendant published from the
letter
for each of you as to whether what the
defendant published or deployed
was arguably
a justifiable interference with those
privacy plans the rights that inhere in
the private information
and if the judge
does the right job which we say he did
in this case
he actually only needs to look
at those three documents
the outer limits what one could perhaps
refer to the book as well and i'll i'll
say a little bit about that later
uh but
if if
the defendant sails under the flag of
well the people article was misleading i
don't need to say it was an attack let's
just say it was misleading it includes
what the defendant says
and we were entitled to correct the
record
which is what they said
what then has to happen is a very close
focus
of what the
letter said
and whether the publication of its
extroverts
was
capable
of serving
the justification that the defendant
relies on namely that the people article
required correction
and the
the judge actually reached three
we would say three cumulative
reasons for saying that
the defendant's deployment of the letter
was
indisputably excessive
it was disproportionate
excessive in terms of quantity
it was clearly more than could be
reasonably necessary judged objectively
to serve the purpose
for which it was ostensibly done
two it wasn't germaine
to the attack and the the
factual errors in the people
and he's right about that for reasons
that
have accounted and there's a third
reason which lord ships and eulasia have
not heard anything about and it does
feature in his i think two parts of his
judgment
which was that it was
precipitate
of the
defendant
to publish those
extensive extracts
in the circumstances that it did now why
is that relevant well
um
our case as it happens factually
and the court will have seen our
completed denials
and the references to it in the judgment
uh is that
what the friend
i think she's called a long time friend
and people argue
said about the letter
in that interview
which was a 24 25
word passing reference
was not authorized by her
and she said she was upset when she
found out
that
the judge was prepared to assume in the
defendant's favor
that despite that denial
she nevertheless had somehow authorized
that characterization or description of
the contents to use the defendant's
phrase
of the letter
in people
but that's not the end of the inquiry
when it comes to public interest
because as he rightly pointed out
accepting um a submission we made below
for all the defendant view
the claimant was right about this
she didn't authorize it
and
one thing that is established well
established
in the um
ethics of journalism
as a matter of domestic
it's absolutely
rule number one in a newspaper lawyer's
office is you've got to go
to the subject of an article of this
kind whether it's going to invade
privacy or libel somebody
and put to them
the story that you're proposing to
publish
and the judge is absolutely right
this if nothing else
would have worked this was
in itself a killer point
in saying the defendant had no right to
assume
that
mr markle was correct or its own
assumption was correct
and that it was authorized by the
claimant
it's pretty obvious although perhaps it
doesn't matter that they didn't go to
her because they didn't want to be met
with an injunction application
you don't have to make a finding about
that but there are consequences
for a newspaper publisher that doesn't
go
to the subject of the story
and say in this case
mr markle's upset about
what your friend has said about him in
people
what do you say about it he's given us
your letter and we're proposing to
publish it
on our case the answer would have come
back don't you dare publish that letter
it's a private letter
and by the way
what the long time friend is quoted as
saying in people
is wrong
we agree
she didn't write it to repair the
relationship that's an inaccurate
characterization
it's one of the few things that is
common ground in this case
i mean you concentrate on that
but as you say that is common ground
and i wonder why you don't
i'm sure you will
come to the points that mr caldecott
made
which the judge did not
recite when he um set out what the
people article said
and did not deal with and just dealt
with in a global fashion
as saying there was nothing else that
mattered
but of course
it may be said it was said by mr
caldecott
that it does matter
that it was said
i can't remember the precise words i'm
afraid that they hadn't
they
the allegations were being traded about
who'd
uh not contacted who and who treated who
truly and all that
stuff i think there were three specific
points mr caldecott made that weren't in
the judges some of it
or dealt with
yes um the the
the reason it was
i will come on to why that was an unfair
criticism but but
um
i i i don't want it to be underestimated
the importance of the failure to contact
because that is absolutely no i and i
get that
because it wouldn't i mean that that may
be an over weaning point if it's right
it is but
um
nonetheless i do think you have to deal
with the three allegations which are the
mr markle had cruelly cold-shouldered
duchess in the pre-wedding period
mr michael had lied and alleging the
duchess had shut him out after the
wedding
and
the duchess was always taking care of
her father with incredible generosity
um
we have a i think a note of them so i
may um want to refine what i say but the
short answer
is that none of the contents of the
letter
were capable
of supporting mr markle's case
on these alleged inaccuracies
that is the to be fair to the judge
there is a a painstaking
analysis of what
the
inaccuracies
about the letter were in people
and he rightly reached the view
that
it was overstated by the defendant
and that the
material enacted what was devastated the
degree of inaccuracy of the
of what people article said about the
letter
mr rushbrook um forgive me for
derailing your train of thought can i go
back to your
starting point tell me if you're coming
to this later in which case it's fine
it's something that's bugging me you you
told us
you referred us to the three
elements of article 8 private life
family life correspondence you said all
these are
engaged
um
uh you said that a letter is more
private even than a photo and so you
said a newspaper that
brings the
contents of a private letter between
family
members
into the public domain has to show a
very good
case to justify it
you've said as
able advocates do you said this as
though it's a self-evident proposition
my question is
does it apply irrespective of how the
newspaper got the letter
in particular is it relevant here it is
the recipient of the letter who gave it
to the newspaper
um
my answer to the lord would be it would
be even worse
if the defendant had got it
um
from
someone who had been um
bribed in the couriers
company i think my lord actually
appeared that to mr
yes uh that would certainly taint the
conscience of the defendant and that
would be one of the things that would
also go into the
murray mix
as
strengthening or
certainly corroborating the article
eight right but
um
of course we don't actually know how
the defendant came right there
we know what we're told
about assuming for present purposes that
that
mr markle happily
volunteered
uh the contents of the letter a copy of
the letter
even the original
uh to the defendant
um it doesn't
we say rescue the defendant
from its obligation
to behave
in accordance with the ethics of
journalism
and proportionately
and to deploy
those contents in a way which is
logically germane
and or putting it another way which
accords with its status stated purpose
um
the fundamental problem in our
submission with the defendants correct
correcting the record depends is that
they're sailing under a false flag and
this is um
approaching an answer to my lord's
question master of the roles
that when one looks at what
is said in the people article about the
letter and yes it does have other
statements in it as well which mr
poltico is very skillfully woven into
his case
but there is a fundamental logical
disconnect between the way in which the
defendant deploys the contract
and the state of purpose for this reason
that the letter doesn't rebut
the criticisms
that's what i was going to ask you about
yes
and
it it of course
doesn't rebut them all
clearly and square on
but it does address the three crit in in
some measure
the three criticisms uh mr caldecott
relied upon from the people article
but lord here's the important thing in
ways which actually don't support mr
markle i actually undermine him
i mean that's thank you so that is a
question i mean
you're right and wrong um
you know unfortunately
both sides in this case do not have a
beautiful set of neatly tailored facts
which mesh perfectly with their own case
or
mesh so as to destroy the other side's
case the fact is it's colorable
and there is it bears upon it
and and if it bears upon it
then surely that
engages the balancing exercise
which also means that the balancing
exercise is better conducted when you've
got facts i mean that's the point that
i think mr caldecott wouldn't yes i
understand the point
um
but
the devil is in the detail we better
have a look at can we have a look at the
letter and the people article so we're
starting from before
um
let me show i don't have to keep coming
back to this
um
the involvement of
the recipient of the letter
are you saying that
there is a general proposition that they
recipient recipient of a private family
letter yes daughter to father
um
the father
is
committing a breach of the daughter's
legal rights if he shows
the letter
to a newspaper or to anyone outside the
family
well of course it will depend on the the
facts yes uh and whether or not the
defendant can bring itself
but there's two questions is the father
liable and is that yes well is the [ __ ]
the the well the the
the court has had to address this issue
uh mckenna is actually probably the best
example but ms ashe wasn't marina
mckenna's father
no she was a
trusted confidante and friend
but the um focus on on family family
letters
my answer to the question would be i'm
not sure if that specific factual um
scenario has arisen but my answer would
be
yes under the modern law of privacy
just because two people even if they are
family members
are privy to doesn't even have to be a
letter could be a secret of some kind
it does not follow
that
either of them is free
to disclose the contents of that
information all those that secret
to a third party
uh and in fact
stevenson avery is probably the starting
point for for
that doctrine
and the answer which the law provides is
that if a
a a parties privy to a relationship of
that kind
wants to exercise their
article 10 or indeed other rights
then
[Music]
the
way in which those rights are protected
has to be crafted
in a way which properly protects
the rights of the owner of the private
information does it not matter what the
information is
so if it is information
about
the claimant
so that if the claimant writes
to her father saying
about her medical condition
herself and private information
obviously private information
i quite understand you're sufficient
but if the claimant writes to the
defense father i'm sorry i'm assuming
the father's a departed for the purposes
of my lord's example
writes to the father and says you are a
bad person
for the following 63 reasons
is that personal information of the
daughter or is that
really personal information of the
father
to which he's fully entitled to say
not only i guess suspect are you writing
this in private letters to me but you're
telling all your friends as well that
you think i'm a bad person and i want to
rebut it in some way
wouldn't normally be a national or
international newspaper in a normal
father-daughter situation
but i think the input of my lord's
question is surely
when you receive a bad letter from
if you're the father i'm sorry i
identify with fathers rather than
doctors
if you're the father rather than the
daughter
you receive a letter from your daughter
saying you're a bad person
surely
that's information that is private to
you
uh
the
no
because no
may be shared information
right
if it
conveys embodies or discloses
the writer's feelings
whether about the father the mother or
anybody else yes
uh the fact that
the feelings may be about the recipient
of the letter
doesn't
reduce or extinguish the claimant's
privacy rights in relation to that
information
so if there is a clash
such that the father wants to divulge
the daughter's feelings
that we are in classic modern law of
privacy territory and the court has to
apply the test
of what is proportional
to the
alleged
right or need on the path of the
recipient comes back to a little fairly
fundamental article eight point which is
comes from mostly from the strengths but
jurisprudence which is the what autonomy
is the individual and the need of an
individual to be able to
interact with other individuals in a in
in a way
that protects their autonomy
about what they do and how they do it
without interference
so it's that's the that's the source of
this
lady i quite agree and roddy which is
cited below and is uh referred to the
judgment
i think encapsulates
the principle
didn't understand mr caldecott to
challenge that as a no premise when he
has other reasons for saying that
in this particular case
notwithstanding that
position there are strong
article 10 and article 8 writes which
and one that's a parallel analysis
override that position
that's respectful
that is the difference between us and
miss justice mumby and rodney is quite
clear
that the article 8 right embraces
the right of control over one's personal
information and
this is stating no more than what
emerges for the first time in account
and that right of control includes
the right
whether or not to disclose personal
information
to whom to disclose it
uh when to disclose it and how to
disclose it
all like applying this to to a daughter
father
suppose royal family isn't involved just
a daughter father letter
and the letter discloses
private information the daughter's
feelings
what she thinks of the father and so on
if you're right then
the
article 8 writes of the doctor mean
that
if
the father
gives notice that he intends to
show this
to the media
the daughter could get an injunction
prohibiting him from doing said
so returning to the present case if if
the claimant had had notice she could
have applied for and got an injunction
prohibiting
a father at least in this jurisdiction
from disclosing to anyone otherwise he
would be sent to president
from disclosing to the media
to the media
that is a very important
part of the proposition
because again it's part of the overall
proportionality analysis it matters not
just what you disclose how much of what
you disclose but to whom you disclose
and to disclose it to a mass media
newspaper
is something that i
had i been instructed to go down and get
an injunction on the fact of this case
and not got one i would have been
failing in my job let me put it that way
coming back to the to to
the question of shared information yes
ultimately this may not matter
because the truth is
nobody is saying there is no privacy in
this lecture
the extent of the privacy
is a question for the balancing exercise
and it's only if the judge and you are
right
that the
factors that mr caldecott said should be
taken into account and were not
are relevant
that you would accept the appeal
succeeds
if you're right and the judge is right
that they are irrelevant then the appeal
inevitably fails yes and so
we don't have to get in like many of the
greater um
reaches of this case we actually don't
need to decide that
interesting question that i agree with
my lord it is an interesting question
it doesn't arise here because everybody
accepts
this is a private letter
in some respects it's our very least
in case it it's helpful to my lord the
judge actually did
deal in some detail with with um
the question of whether or not it was
shared
personal information yeah between the
claimed and the father and in my
respectful submission his analysis was
absolutely right which
this is 76
um
one
and he and down to two
and three
and then four has a reference to
mckenith and my lord lord justice bean's
question is to some extent addressed in
free
the shared experience
uh point
so it's not i think all i need to say is
this is not a a a new or a difficult
question the courts are used to
grappling with it on the fact of this
case as you say is no dispute even
between malone and friend and me
but the letter was to some extent
private and personal to the claimant
but he's he's entirely right we submit
to say at the bottom of page 142.
it was in short a personal private
letter the majority of what was
published was about the claimant's own
behavior her feelings of anguish about
her fellow's behavior as she saw it and
the resulting rift between them
these are inherently private and
personal massive matters he then goes on
to address the
question of to what extent the father
might have
claimed
ownership of the private information and
um
he largely rejects that proposition
again he's right to do so because it's
the claimant's own account
what one of the um
benefits if it can be put this way of a
modern law privacy is that we don't
allow a freefall
where people are enabled to
put private letters
which may well have mixed ownership of
private information
into the pages of the mail on sunday
and then force them to argue it out
about who's right who's wrong who owns
how much information and whose right
should prevail and that is
with respect to the learned friend that
is what the law is there to
prevent
so so you place some reliance on the
fact
um really so my lord's question was
fortuitous
because you placed some reliance on the
fact that had you gone down to court to
get an injunction
you would have got it yes
and i mean that may not be in any way
conclusive because you only have to
share a good argument case not um
maybe a bit more first privacy in
junction but you don't have to show
your band to win
we have sure that we're we are likely to
be likely to win but you don't have to
shave your band to win
but it gets you somewhere if you're back
the lord absolutely and um
[Applause]
it would not be surprising
if the court had not or the judge below
had not um at least privately speculated
as to why the defendant
didn't notify us of what they were
proposing to do i mean i don't have win
i'm sorry
they're likely to win is section 12
correct exactly
section 12 junction yes
it's a higher test than cyanomid yes and
it involves a sliding scale so likely
doesn't have to be more
more likely than not if the information
is particularly prone to damage or
sensitive but that's the broad scheme of
it and i'd be content with more likely
than not for present purposes
but um the lord can i also be clear in
case mr kulka jumps down my throat on
this
um
we're not saying that the court needs to
find
and we're not saying
that the court needs to find that we
would definitely have been right
about my underlying factual proposition
but that even the claimant didn't want
this in people
but one thing is for sure is that that
very question
would have been crystallized
in the injunction application
so we would have put in our evidence to
say hold on this is a private letter
you've got no business publishing it
defendant comes back and said ah
look at the people
you've mischaracterized
the purpose of the letter
which we say actually
you're correct that it is
mischaracterized but we did not
authorize it
and once that has been said and unfriend
accepted that it could have been
corrected but seeks to criticize us for
not doing so
once that had
as it were crystallized in the
list of the injunction stage the entire
pretext
for this article would have fallen away
as it was in the summary judgment case
um
which we're
dealing with
the judge you're saying the judge
assumed for the sake of argument what he
had to
that the
the defendant's case in relation to the
claimant's responsibility for what
emerged in the people
um was a good one he did
that's the starting
point because there is another question
which is
in reply to attack cases it has
defamation it has to be established that
you're responding to
an
attack by the person who attacked
and you say
i mean you say
think that we should assume that that
was done deliberately because otherwise
it wouldn't have happened i do i do say
that and if my lord is um
understandably reluctant to go so far
well i understand i mean not but not
must have been a factor i mean these are
professional people who understand
what's going on
and and the lord i don't drink from this
it is absolutely
less than one its mother's milk to the
nightwear
you put the story to the subject what
did the judge say about the deliberate
nature of it the injunction did he say
he didn't um he he he rightly um held
back from saying well i i can't accept
as a fact that that's what would have
emerged but he did accept and this is
the important bit that it might have
emerged and that and that's the reason
for his precipitate which which
um because you told us it was very
important
it doesn't immediately leap out uh the
page to someone reading the judgment
with fresh eyes but if
um
120 yes my lord's word search is better
than mine
at 120 he he tease up the point
with precipitous
um but he then
addresses it that full on at one two
five and two
by saying i don't consider it was
necessarily proportionate for mr
martinez to pursue this legitimate
objective in the way that they did
by publishing long and success
sensational articles revealing and
commenting commenting on extensive
extracts from the letter here's the
important bit without first approaching
the claimant
it is clear that neither mr markle nor
the defendant knew whether or not the
people article had the claimant's
blessing
for all they knew this publication was
as the claimant says it was an
unauthorized step
at all events adopting a proportionate
approach the logical first step should
have been an attempt to establish the
facts and to see whether the inaccuracy
might be corrected by the people
responsible for publishing
so all the jeopardy
of the assumption
turning out to be incorrect
all the damage in terms of invasion
falls
on us
and we say that is not
convention compliant when it comes to
article 8 rights
and will orders uh um
law justice war he was absolutely right
to include that in his it's really a
trilogy in fact it's not proportionate
it's not germaine and in any event it
was presented
he referred to the code at one point
and
i can i couldn't find it well the lord
you're quite right if i may say so
he did refer to it
and
this does bear upon the um
what my call that one might call the
burden of proof point
um
which i will come on to but in campbell
if your lord if my lord and my lady have
bundle one
campbell
includes
in lord in baroness hale's
speech
um
the relevant extract from the ipso code
at 159.
and does my lord
i mean there's two aspects of the code
that are relevant for for these purposes
one is the without consent which might
be thought to be obvious but it it is
built into the code
um
the public interest expressly
includes
um
preventing the public from being misled
by some statement or action of an
individual organization and that was
slap bang the
the
window through which the defendant
sought to go
but does my lord see that the the
architecture of the code is that you
start off with a
um
if i can call this a non-legal
presumption at least
that if you are intruding into
somebody's private life
without their consent
you've got to be expected to justify
that
and
when one looks further down at the
language on pub exceptions public
interest exceptions
it's where they can be demonstrated
to be in the public interest who has to
do the demonstrating while it's the
editor
speaking through his or her lawyers
so that is why um
it's one of the reasons why as it
happens maloney friends criticism of i
think it was paragraph 36 of the
judgment
uh
was unfair
uh insofar as it is said that the
defendant didn't have to show anything
that's my friend's point he's wrong
where you've got
private information
disclosed being disclosed by an ipso
subscriber
um without consent it's for the
defendant to justify
but having said that this is not a case
when one looks at the judgment which the
judge actually decided on the burden of
approve anyway it's a bit of a non-point
for the purposes of this case because
it's quite clear when one looks i'll
come on to this in the quit on the on
the question of the so-called errors of
law
but he he conducted the the balancing
exercise and the parallel analysis
um
according to his direction at
paragraph 35
sorry i'm sorry sorry 31.
[Applause]
it was my submission of 35 that he
recited about um
the defendant failing to charge the
burden but 31 he
what mr caldecott even the learned
friend accepted yesterday was that 31 is
an unexceptionable it's an entirely
campbell compliant correct
direction as to what the judge had to do
and with great respect to malone and
friend the idea that by the time he got
to carrying out
the analysis that he sets out in writing
at page paragraph 103 and following by
the time he got to that point he'd
forgotten
about what he directed himself to do is
frankly totally unrealistic
i think on this point he he relies on
the
interposition of the word necessary
disproportionate yes and although i will
have a bit
to say on that because
um without going too far ahead if one
looks at the context in which the word
necessary is used
uh it's
it's clear that he's actually using it
in the
the campbell sense that baroness hail
and lord carls will use it in other
words as a proxy for justified or is it
ultimately justified
but there is another point
which um
uh
struck us as quite remarkable uh which
which is that it's the defendant's own
pleaded case
by way of justification
that it was necessary
and he recites that
at
paragraph 117
when he sets out 1513 paragraph 15.13.
halfway down that citation
he quotes from the defense it was
necessary proper and in the public
interest to publish the true and full
story
concerning the letter and the response
to it including mr markle's account of
events
this was necessary for the sake of true
fairness and mr markle's reputation
it's
a harsh thing to criticize the judge
when he then comes on to
reject
essentially that
pleaded defense of necessary
to say that they've missed he's
misdirected himself
can i ask you a question
um
is it possible
or a
an infringement of privacy
to be
categorically
such an infringement
at
an early stage
before
public inquiries and journalistic
practice has been undertaken by a
newspaper
which might not
at a later stage
when further
material had been ascertained by that
journalist
journalistic outlet
um
which might justify
the
um
the disclosure that wouldn't have been
justified before in other words
could you get some judgment for the
publication four days after the people's
article
in the circumstances you very
carefully explained
but
um
not get some of the judgment if the
hoops had gone through
in relation to the same disclosure or
very similar disclosure six weeks later
saying
the right to control the dissemination
uh
um
um
i understand
um
um
is
positions
um um
the
message um
is
which were not only
right
um
um
yes
you need to understand the thing as a
whole
yes because other because otherwise you
don't properly do the balancing exercise
the judge did and the judge was
meticulous in his assessment
of what it was
uh in each of the
um
unfairnesses or inaccuracies in the
people article
that the extracts from the letter in the
articles
were capable
of rebutting
on behalf of mr mark
and he came to the entirely correct
conclusion
that nothing
that was published from the letters
actually was capable logically of doing
that
and the obvious reason and you say
that's why mr caldecott
is forced to go to the furthest reaches
of this case by saying
well
actually in the people article there
were these three specific
callous whatever the words are
um which he didn't specifically address
but you say that doesn't address the
main question yes
it doesn't work to say
mr markle was entitled to reply to the
people
and then
publish a whole load of extracts from
the letter
which do not and are not capable of
rebutting the criticisms in the people
in people i mean
as your example but i expect you're
going to take the puppeteering exam
yes i think it's fair to say that um
most of the
um
extracts
in
[Music]
it italics be helpful to look again at
the people articles yes there was beings
we were
sorry the article was responding to
yes because
as my lady says that the people the
thrust i mean i don't want to
oversimplify the case
and i don't think the judge did that
he certainly did
something bad says he didn't
but
um
it is important to have a proper global
view of the case and we didn't look at
much of the people article any bits of
it and i think it's best to read it yes
well um
core bundle
one through three seven
seven is where the text starts three
seven seven
tab 21 i'm so sorry
[Applause]
started at um
377
and
he started with the uh i don't know what
the correct journalistic word for it is
but the okra yellow
block in the middle of the page at the
top
contains a reference to
thomas has said she shut him up claims
her friends say i'll hate to be false
i'm just taking that exam
the letter
and again
it doesn't have to be true
it just has to be capable of either
supporting or rebutting the allegation
but the
letter
i think i'd i'd better
keep one
eye on the original of the letter sorry
the version of that is in the bundle
because not all the important bits
uh or the allegedly responsive bits were
included in the article but
um
the
part of i think it's the first paragraph
of the letter
yes
where are we
in the judge's judgment
i i fear not my lord um
the the letter is in the supplementary
bundle at 306.
it's probably easier to have that
probably won't be easy for my lord
i'm sorry
you can jump back and forth
competitiveness
306 of the supplementary
[Applause]
very kindly asked what they could do to
help and i said it was too late
um
i'm grateful this is actually um it's
not the whole letter
this is the whole letter
and just for um
for rep for complete accuracy the
passages that are in highlight
bold and underlining
are those that were published so this is
a helpful uh reference point for that
which the defendant published yes
if your lord if you launch it would look
at the first paragraph
from my phone alone i called you over 20
times and you ignored my calls
leaving me in the days before our
wedding worried confused shocked and
absolutely blindsided
um
that
far from constituting a rebuttal of what
mr markle is upset about on page 377
that supports
what
the claims of the friends
right um
the next that's very important too
i'm so sorry that's very important to
realize that much of what is published
is actually simply further support
exactly
exactly
exactly so
um
if we move on to the next passage that
murder friend referred to which is the
uncaring daughter one
um
there is
nothing
not only is there nothing in this letter
that could constitute a
rebuttal of that criticism but
to a large extent
both its underlying premise and
a lot of what it says such as i've only
ever loved protected and defended you
offering whatever financial support i
could worrying about your health always
asking how i could help so the weeks
week of the wedding to hear about you
having a heart attack through a tablet
is horrifying
uh
that is probably for my purposes good
enough
as another example of
um an extract from the letter used in an
article
which far from
doing the job that the defendant says it
does does the opposite i would suggest
or at least undermines it
i mean it's the same thing it supports
yes
exactly
um
the
i'm not sure if it was the very next
passage but um
on 378
we get into the heart of what it was
that
was relied on as the pretext
i'll take this i'd better take this
carefully if i may because there's a lot
of different allegations in here we can
read it if it's easier
yes
is this the paragraph that starts and
wild
uh it's uh no it's um
top of three seven eight right hand
column next uh long time friend the
saturday before the wedding
so if
would you mind just reading that whole
paragraph first
the saturday before the wedding
uh and the lord on going back to the
letter
at 307
uh
just above the
middle of the page
is a sentence that starts to remember
our conversation seven days before the
wedding
when we asked you if the claims of you
working with the paparazzi and press
were true
would my lords and my lady just read
down to
the end of that paragraph
now you're just going to have to tell me
which pancakes a little behind you uh
the
307 yeah
uh there's a just above the middle
there's a passage that starts to
remember our conversation seven days
before the wedding
when we asked you if the claims of you
working with the paparazzi and press
were true and told you if we tried to
protect you from the story running
something we've never attempted to do
for anyone ourselves included that we
wouldn't be able to use that strength to
protect our own children one day even
knowing that you said it wasn't true i
believed you trusted you and told you i
loved you
the next morning the cctv footage came
out you haven't reached out to me since
the week of our wedding
uh in fact i ought to read on
and while you claim you have no way of
contacting me my phone number has
remained the same this you know no text
no miss calls no outreach from just more
global interviews
um
my lord will will see that
the latter part of that paragraph was
also published by the defendant
although not the bit um in the middle
which is not highlighted
which finishes just before i believed
you trusted you and told you i loved you
but the relevant
what one collects from
the passage
on 307
is
a pretty direct
recital of the facts surrounding what
if i can call it the the fake paparazzi
lie
all told from the claimant's
perspective
none of it
uh reflecting well on the father
what is published picking it up in the
highlighting on 307
that i believed you trusted you and told
you i loved you that's more
rebuttal of the uncaring daughter
interwoven with
what follows about the cctv footage
which uh on um
her case and as it as it happens
accepted by the judge as it was it was
bound to be mr markle accepted he agreed
that he had lied and he apologized for
it
so nothing in this letter could possibly
have rebutted
uh the
passage under longtime friend on page
378 because the story
of the staged uh paparazzi photographs
and
uh mr markle lying about it was true it
was a true bill for which he apologized
so whilst mr caldecott is entitled to
say
picking up on
the reference to lying
and the way in which the the long time
friend uh tells the story
yes that doesn't reflect at all well in
this democracy totally accept that
but the letter doesn't do that no the
problem is it's true and the letter the
letter really adds more detail
messages where he um he is apologetic to
be fair
and he offers to issue a public apology
but
this all comes a few days after the
conversation on the eve of the mail
sunday scoop
where they published the story
for the claimant and her husband having
offered to try to kill the story
and hear the claimant saying this is a
big step for us to take because if we do
it and we're we're wrong
and we're trying to kill a true story
then we may be losing our own privacy
the privacy of our children
notwithstanding that says the claimant
you told us the story wasn't true
and then the cc tv footage came out so
the story was true
um and the way it's dealt with
this is all of a piece you said yes
you say nothing in the letter or i mean
in a sense it's simple because the
letter comes from
it from the same
quite sort of quite but i suppose um
i suppose it could be said to be used to
support a claim that
she was heartless because it wasn't
at that point we are entering into the
the bit that the judge took great care
over
and
was scrupulous to analyze which was the
complaint
well it was the
uh sorry i've not been
clear the
the judge was
prepared in the defendant's favor
to accept that the letter could have
been deployed
to about the olive branch
allegation
um
it doesn't matter i don't think
uh this court needs to to rule on our
rival submissions about whether it's
defamatory or an attack on mr markle the
point is
both sides agree it was untrue that this
character right there was a
mischaracterization of the letter it was
not
exactly and so the bit that
on the defendant's account
mr markle got so worked up about
and which is the um
foundation upon which this entire
edifice
is based
is
the words
so we can repair our relationship 378
i said it was 24 or 25 words the the
word count starts at
dad i'm so heartbroken i love you i have
one father
please stop victimizing me through the
media so we can repair our relationship
close quotes
now
as i say that was the the trigger or the
pretext
for the defendant's publication and it's
it's there
in the article it's a strand in the
article
and one finds it in the um
the block text underneath
the
first article on
does my lord have the um
the a3 copies
which have the um
the revealed the letter showing true
tragedy of megan's rift with the father
this is the first of the articles sooner
and
in the sub-headline in block text how
megan's media fight back led her dad to
reveal letter he wanted to keep secret
one finds this quotation in the third
column
uh from mr markle the letter was
presented in a way that vilified me and
wasn't true he said last night
it was presented as her reaching out and
writing a loving letter in the hope of
healing the rift but the letter isn't
like that at all megan can't have it
both ways she can't use the press to get
her message across but hang me out to
dry um will you launch it please note
the start of that quote the letter was
presented
the letter was presented in people
magazine that is the focus of mr
markle's
um
grievance
and my lord is quite right to say that
that is where
the judge
was very careful we would say
to give proper weight
to the question
of how might
the
mr markle through the defendant
rebut that inaccuracy
doesn't matter for present purposes
whether it's true or not
that's just giving you the power
of the judgment
yes
[Applause]
the
his conclusion starts at one two three
he deals with the handwriting article
very very one might say dismissively at
one two two
uh but at one two three he deals with
the
what he regards as the material
inaccuracy of the people's
articles account of the letter
perhaps i could just ask the court to
read read down to
the end of one two five one two five
five
despair
i'm going to listen to my voice
four
this was an aspect of the claimant's
criticism exactly exactly he seemed to
rebut it by equating
mr martin yes
the letter is is used
as a vehicle
rather than
actually being a rebuttal
if i was being cynical with lord i would
say it was obvious that the defendant
was
regaling its reading
with sensational extracts from a long
letter
and
along the way allowing us to market the
opportunity to critique
the criticisms it contains so it's
happily riding both horses and selling
these things
and so when he says necessary or
proportionate as you said before
it's really justified
for the reasons he's given before
quite so and he could have been achieved
by proportion proportionately by
publishing of the battle consisting
of the sunday
which is what i said in fact you don't
need this forward
the lord is quite right to ask that
question because
the
the extract on
i don't know if you're using a numbered
version but
yeah um
it's page it's page five of the internal
[Music]
one has the heading the bottom of the
block of extract come out of rabbit hole
if you love me as you tell the president
please stop please allow us to live our
lives in peace please stop lying please
stop creating so much pain please stop
it's waiting my relationship with my
husband i realize you've been so far
down this rabbit hole you feel there's
no way out but if you take a moment to
pause i think you'll see that being
absolutely clear conscious is more
valuable than any payment in the world
that is um what the judge describes
at
the paragraph that the law just referred
to
as
paragraph 15 of the letter
and if one looks at
one two five sub-paragraph four
do you see
he concludes
a point that we made which doesn't i
think find its way into this judgment is
that
even the way the defendant deployed this
paragraph
was unfair
because what they left out
were the closing words
in the letter
i ask for nothing more than peace and i
wish to say
it doesn't perhaps make any difference
given the conclusion the judge made in
any event but what i should take
according to
is what he says about the one two seven
it's really a belt of grace
but
they didn't even deploy
paragraph 15
as a revival of the oligarch
it's just there
with the rabbit hole headline
and um such a rebuttal as
one finds
is on an entirely different subject it's
about the use of an american using the
word exactly yes
so again it's false flag and it's sinner
as my lord has said
the
article in the body
does at some level
and um
i would say with
a reasonable degree of conviction of
detail
afford mr mark
his right of correction
there's the references i've already the
reference i already took you to under
the
sub headline and then there's the
various passages in the
text for example paragraph 11
i thought it would be an olive branch
and said it was a dagger to the heart mr
martin said last night
now i don't
to the avoidance of that i don't say
that the defendant should have confined
itself to
giving mr novel
the microphone
to rebut this or correct response
characterization
um
they could have deployed some of the
text of the letter
it doesn't even matter perhaps whether
or not one agrees that it's paragraph 15
i submit is absolutely
the
right
quote to use
what matters is that on any view
what's being deployed is excessive
not jamaican not logically
and that's before we get to the facility
yes
well i think i was sort of in the middle
of the people article um
could i just quickly finish off on that
if we go back to three seven eight well
we read the right hand column
long time frame yes
and then if you could
just read on to the photo op
uh this is um about seven lines up from
the bottom of the right hand corner on
three seven eight oh yeah he writes her
a really long letter in return and he
closes it
her telephone number hasn't changed he's
never called he's never texted
um
that
encapsulates two points for two
criticisms
there is the photo of
criticism
chips passing in the night
and then there's the complaint that he's
never called he's never tasted
um
dealing with the latter first
i think i've already taken you to
material in the letter
which is to price precisely the same
effect
so again same point implies
nothing in the letter that could serve
to look like that
well then the whole letter is about
is it complaining about
the kind of thing yes that the page
reflects yes it's it's
the gist of the complaint is stop going
to the press and then
i wish
i offered nothing other than peace but
stop going to the press she's not
actually closing down
but she's making it clear please stop
um
so is there anything apart from the
olive branch nature
that the judge accepted
did allow the letter to be
used
and i hope i'm not mischaracterizing it
by saying that he says well you need to
look at
the characterization of the letter
and the added
as it were criticism
about
what comes back in reply the photo
and the learning affair would no doubt
say that the criticism
about the photo is sharper
or made worse by what preceded them
and i accept that's a fair point but
only up to the real question is how
could anything in the meta
have served
to
further mr markle's purpose in rebutting
the people
the problem is that again as the judge
rightly found
the photo op
charge was a true bill
from the
um
and the judge
we submit was entirely right to say
that nothing from the letter
could make that point any better
the reference to the facts
mr miller how's
yes it's 114-115
the key bit is
ending with i'm unable to detecting
these paragraphs any logical or arguably
sufficient basis
disclosing any part
it's the second of the articles
megan stop painful attacks on harry
right hand side of the of the a3 spread
under you can hate me
where the
extract from mr markle's reply
is set out
self-evidently with mr markle's lesson
what the point of judge makes is
entirely right he can't complain about
equal articles characterization he may
not like it
but it's
at the time the the one
well um
it would uh suit me anyway if we were to
break a little early tonight
um
how are we doing
i'm
confident we'll be within our
collectively
um
we will
do that and we'll resume
hmm
you